صرخات مليئه بالغضب والاسى من هذه المراه
التي تسير مع غيرها من سكان المنطقه بينما
ينبعث الدخان المتصاعد من النيران في افق
المدينه هذا الفيديو الذي رفع على موقع
يوتيوب يظهر ما يزعم انه مجموعه من سكان
مدينه حراك وهم يغادرون منازلهم حفاظا على
حياتهم حاملين معهم حقائب وممتلكات وبعض
زجاجات المياه الكثير منهم يحملون اطفالا
في اياديهم وتظهر اصابات وارهاق بعضهم بعد
ايام من القتال في مدينه حراك الكثير من
السكان سرد قصصا لكيفيه قتل العديد من
شباب المدينه اضافه الى قتل وحرق جثث
الكثير من
الاطفال العنف الذي تمارسه القوات
النظاميه ترك مؤيدي الثوار في ياس ورغم ان
ماره حاولوا تهدئه هذا الرجل الا انه لم
يستطع ان يحتوي
مشاعره مدينه حراك تقع شمال درعا حيث بدات
الثوره العام الماضي وقد اتخذ الجيش
السوري الحر المدينه التي تقع بالقرب من
الحدود الاردنيه كقاعده عسكريه له لفتره
طويله وقد دفع سكان المنطقه الثمن اليوم
ويظهر فيديو اخر ما يزعم انه محلات محروقه
واثار واضحه لقذائف الدبابات وربما كان
ذلك سبب اشتعال النيران في
المباني وقد بقي بعض سكان المدينه رغم
الخطر الذي يحوم
بالمنطقه ويسارع سكان المدينه للجوء الى
مناطق مجاوره اكثر امنا على متن الشاحنات
الصغيره وقد يحاول بعضهم الخروج من سوريا
تماما في خطوه لتوفير مستقبل افضل لاطفال
شهدوا الكثير من المعاناه والالم في
بلادهم
نراك انقذوا نساء الاح راك حسبنا الله
ونعم الوكيل حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل